Thanks to Amazon prime video for sponsoring this episode.
Hey, wisecrack,
Michael here to talk about our favorite mustachioed reporter for at sag DF,
between giving you an uncontrollable urge to say my wife and very nice to every
person you see this subsequent movie film created more than a few headlines,
about a certain prank on one Rudolph, Giuliani, but political pranking aside,
I'd like to propose a different way to look at the film as a wholesome,
inspiring fairytale.
Sex attack with me.
If your father was not here.
Well, not Polson anything but wholesome, but a fairytale.
Nonetheless,
welcome to this wisecrack edition on four at subsequent movie film and spoilers
ahead. First,
a recap after humiliating his native Kazakh stand with his first film or at now
spends his days doing hard labor as punishment.
But after the election of Donald Trump,
the premier of Catholics down is looking for an in with America's head of state,
which is why he wants to send our disgrace to journalists to America with
Kazakhstan's prized possession, Johnny, the monk from there,
let's just say things don't go so well for Johnny
stuck with no monkey and his feral child to tar who definitely didn't eat.
Johnny Bora has to improvise a new plan. He will gift to tar,
to vice president Michael Pence.
Perfect. She will be sexy gift for Michael pants.
Beautiful father daughter journey follows that bore at subsequent movie film is
a twisted take on traditional fairytales is telegraphed from the beginning.
Once upon a time,
there was a lonely passing girl called in Alanya coal country slogan.
This cartoon version of Melania Trump,
who must escape her whole country by marrying a rich and powerful man is a
pretty obvious stand-in for your typical Cinderella character who similarly
needs to escape her whole home and sisters. Of course, Cinderella.
Isn't the only fairy tale with this theme.
Plenty of stories from history shared the basic premise that if you're a woman
and life sucks, Marianne up and everything will be okay.
Well incorrectly called the original Cinderella.
There is a story told by the Greek geographer Strabo of a cortison named Rhoda
Fez court is in, by the way,
is a sex worker who services high profile clientele, a fate.
She escapes when an Eagle steels or sandal and drops it on the King.
The King who seemingly judge people based on the shape of their feet met and
married rotavirus.
This tale of upward mobility via footwear of course shares a key similarity to
Cinderella.
Her fairy godmother gives her a sick make-over and sends her off to impress a
Prince out of Royal vault.
A glass slipper is lost and the Prince searches for the mysterious woman that
wooed him. The point is Cinderella's suit cover days are over.
Once she marries the right guy,
Bourret takes the already fairly depressing premise of Cinderella,
strips it to its core and makes it Oh, so much darker to tar.
Isn't a lowly servant.
She is just a woman from one of the world's most backward countries.
That country being a fictionalized version of [inaudible],
which we will refer to as fake Kazakhstan as the real country does not to my
knowledge, let monkeys hold public office.
Kazakhstan's minister of culture, a number one porno star.
To be true to its fairytale roots.
Bhorat transports us to a land that seemingly hasn't developed since Charles
Perot wrote the familiar Cinderella tale in 1,697.
Brokers leaped from our dollar skyscraper.
And to say that fake Kazakhstan's views on women might be more welcome around
the 17th century is an understatement.
But nice [inaudible] because.
They're not allowed to have jobs or, you know, do much of anything.
This is her ball. Um,
it make her feel safe just like once upon a time,
the strings in her brain might break. If you try to attend church.
So be careful place it's worth noting that.
Less extreme version of this outrageous claim was common well into the 20th
century.
It was believed even amongst some doctors that if a woman used her brain,
it would divert energy from her womb and thus cause serious harm to her health.
Is that Rosie [inaudible].
Anyway,
instead of being covered in SU like Cinderella to Tara is covered in hay dirt,
and maybe a little animal manure.
Basically the film is a blast from a past where the science of women's stuff was
about as advanced as they flat earthers view of the cosmos.
My dad is the smartest person in the whole flat world, but of course.
We're adding to target journey out of the past and to modern America,
a land where the story of Cinderella is just a popular Relic from the past,
right? Well, yes, sand, no, as the film constantly questions,
how America's own modern fairytales might be just as backwards as those of a
fake Kazakhstan or 17th century Europe.
Basically Brad wants us to see how America is also a magical land,
where a very lucky lady can find a King or a Rudolph Giuliani
that's because two tars journey is of course a modern American Cinderella story.
Cinderella TBAs mom. Lamborn.
Not only does she get a new wardrobe,
but a fake tan look color is best for a racist family and a haircut that would
make dog, the bounty Hunter proud, and burettes twisted fairytale.
The best way for a woman to live a decent life is to drastically alter her
appearance until she can attract and marry a rich guy.
Who's preferably on death's door.
You like them. That's the question and the end of the debt. Okay.
Then you should get someone who just had a heart attack. Yes. Okay. High five.
I love that.
I feel like a gross and antiquated narrative,
but it also seems plenty familiar to many of the films targets other relics of a
time,
more familiar to Cinderella Prince charming versus today like debutante balls
and centuries past a debutante was literally just a woman who was old enough to
finally marry.
And those balls were basically a way for families to show off their daughters,
to eligible bachelors who could, uh, come and get it as it works.
Sandra Jessica Parker drumming.
And while we might say that present day,
debutante balls are about flexing etiquette and father daughter bonding.
We also get comments like this.
That's what we'd love. Yeah. In the South pretty girls.
Or a guy who jokingly gives to tar. I mean,
Sandra Jessica Parker Drummond a monetary event.
How much you think my daughter is worth
$500. Ooh.
And he does so right in front of his disgusted child.
All roads.
Of course, if we want to take refuge in the fact that in America,
women can have jobs go to debutante balls while on their moon blood.
You're able to do a lot of things.
Even though we have womanly things that we go through every
moon time you're talking about.
No on board wants to constantly explore the boundary of what we find acceptable
and why.
So having a come and get it ball for your 15 year old is maybe a okay,
but a blood-soaked fertility dance seems to go too far for polite Southern
society.
One dresses up a basic biological reality behind a facade of etiquette and
customs. While one puts that reality right in your face.
Whereas in fake Kazakhstan,
a woman must live in a cage to be financially supported by a man and real
America. The cage gets a bit metaphorical.
Women are often implicitly and explicitly encouraged or forced to contort
themselves in the quest to find a love slash stability. In this light,
we could consider the words of 18th century philosopher, Mary Wollstonecraft,
also a mother of history's greatest goth who wrote that women are taught from
infancy. That beauty is Herceptin. As a result,
the mind shapes itself to the body and roaming around its guilt cage only seeks
to adorn its prison.
As.
If living in Walston crafts, gilded cage,
a self-identified sugar baby admits to,
to Tara that for her dreams to come true,
she should remain submissive and also change everything about herself.
And if the message wasn't clear when to tar asks,
what she can do for mental liker, her mentor suggest you get a makeover.
Face the hair to clothes, to personality.
That's right. Even her personality has to go. Not only that,
she's unable to use her God given strength.
My is strong. I can open up there with my small hole.
And unlike in Walston crafts time,
a woman's Sceptre of beauty can be surgically enhanced.
According to society's demands,
enter plastic surgeons who seem happy to give women their own supposedly ugly
duckling story by making them feel bad about their noses.
What's real quick. My nose.
All in the business of finding Prince charming. I want [inaudible].
To be a trend to top level guy.
The fictionalization of Kazakhstan's backwardness is really important here
because as the story goes, life in America is a fairy tale.
We're in the land of abundance of equality.
Pizzas with crust made out of breadsticks.
And so on fake Kazakhstan is less a dig at real Kazakh,
Stan and more a dig on how some Americans view the rest of the world is some
kind of backwater nightmare,
a faraway land without the magic of castles and fairy godmothers. If you will.
The distress film,
look of the intro with translations over Russian text connects fake Kazak Stan
with the image of a backward Soviet Republic that an American viewer might
conjure up gulags and all.
But when barrette comes to America and finds his worst views, often welcomed,
the viewer has left a question how advanced he really are.
Who wants to chop them up like the Saudis dude.
But the idea isn't just that bad people do bad things.
Although that's certainly a part of it it's that people are convinced to love,
or at least tolerate their cages metaphorical or otherwise, or ad I'd argue,
wants to raise the question.
Defense details have a role in convincing women that it's normal,
even desirable to change your personality and appearance and your search for
love to tar raised on this weird daughters owner manual and the millennia story
begs for a nice cage for her husband to keep her not unlike our sugar baby
expert Tusar has learned how to behave according to social expectations.
Ones that demand submission even weakness from women in search of Prince
charming. Of course,
it's not fair to say that women in America are still living in the 19th century
or even pseudo Kazic Stan. And this has played for laughs.
As Borat is surprised that a woman can own a store.
[Inaudible] business.
Uh, [inaudible] call up Dom
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] truth.
Or to target learns that women can drive.
They can drive.
Unlike the first movie,
subsequent movie film is not only happy to roast people for saying and doing
awful things, but to show that it's not all hopeless,
even our conspiracy theorists pushed back against Borats claim that women can't
think the women, yeah.
Here have rights. They can do whatever they want.
They have a brain like we have a brain.
Then they wished that their political opponents have less rights than they do.
So, uh, we're one for two.
They should have a bit less rights than you
say they should.
By exploring modern America through the eyes of a disgrace journalist and an
idealistic daughter raised on fairytale narratives at subsequent movie film is
able to shine a light on many dark corners of American culture.
If the classic fairytale teaches young women that they'll finally be happy and
whole, once they have the adoring gaze of a Prince,
the fairytale we get in this film is one where our heroine realizes her own
self-worth.
Betsy go to.
So while us and de may have taught the sag Diaz about fashion,
mobile technology goes to.
With blue shirt, answer me. You are a.
Demon and journalistic integrity.
Maybe the sag Diaz also taught us something about ourselves also to
tar, definitely ate Johnny alive. And that's something we all have to live with.
Now, this, all,
this is a big component of subsequent movie film pranks while Sasha Baron Cohen
has been pranking establishment figures for decades.
It's worth understanding the long list of historical pranksters who paved his
way. You know,
people who dumped a bunch of money on wall street and watch people fight each
other for it were the famous comedian who roasted dating shows by appearing in
costume and crying when he lost. So what does Borat have to do with that?
And people's creepy PayPal. Effigies,
you'll have to check it out in our subsequent YouTube video film that we made
featuring yours. Truly.
It gets into some honestly cool history of messing with people it's over at the
Amazon prime video YouTube channel,
which you can find by clicking here and be sure to subscribe and tell them
wisecrack sent you.
Thanks again to Amazon prime video for sponsoring us to cover at one of our
favorite artists and as always, thanks for watching later.
[Inaudible].